that's where the Republicans on Capitol
Hill think about it for a moment take a
lesson from the Democrats they never
break ranks think about what you
Republicans accomplished by supporting
the president during the confirmation
fight of Brett Kavanaugh when things got
tough when the media were piling on
Republicans stood firm do it again here
the Democrats are desperate to divide
and conquer the GOP don't let them well
that was my message to the GOP on Monday
stay unified on issues of really big
import to the country and great results
are gonna follow well despite reports
the contrary president Trump earlier
today brushed off concerns that the GOP
unity was cracking the Republicans are
unified we want border security we want
safety for our country well still there
are some like congressman Adam Kinzinger
showing signs of well weakness if it is
again if it's an agreeable bill
agreeable appropriations I'll reopen as
much government as we can this is like a
super easy issue to solve and this is
what just frustrates me out here is we
can all solve this and it's like an 80%
agreement with when we're done it's just
nobody wants to give anybody a win or
anything else we got to get past that or
we're gonna continue in this stupid
shutdown idiocy cycle here to tell us
where his caucus actually stands the man
in charge of the GOP vote house Minority
Whip Steve Scalise congressman Scalise
even after this speech that was so well
received is the president really facing
defections Laura not really I mean
frankly what you're seeing is a growing
Lea Unified Conference vice president
Pence came last night to speak to our
members and really gave a very passioned
plea about what this is all about and
then of course you saw the president he
joined eight seven other Republicans
today to vote for partially funding the
government a financial services
appropriations bill so bad in Ken's
Agurs
you know he's he's kind of tweaked the
president a number of issues Syria and
other things well but keep in mind the
media was reporting before that vote
that there were going to be 25
Republican to
factions go read the political article
I'm the Republican vote counter we were
never anywhere close to that and sure
enough you know we thought maybe a dozen
or less we ended up with eight so when
they reported 25 and there ended up
beating eight I'm sure they're gonna be
a lot of reports tomorrow saying that
they were wrong in the end the president
laid out I think a very passionate
article in place yesterday about why
were today at a meeting today that you
were at with the president and Chuck
Schumer comes on TV and said the
president it's his favorite word tantrum
I always say it's like psychological
projection because last night buddies
had more tantrums than Chuck Schumer
watching he and Nancy Pelosi last night
led the Green Acres segment that they
gave in the end they had no rebuttal to
what the president said is a crisis at
the border and so when you see Nancy
Pelosi and I've been in these meetings
now this is the third meeting we've had
in the last week and Nancy Pelosi will
start off by saying I'm for border
security and the president say okay how
can you say you're for border security
I need funding for border security and
she will not agree to a dime and so last
week the only time she's ever put an
alternative on the table was when last
week she jokingly Laura said she'd
support a dollar now any American out
there no matter what side of this debate
you're on regarding immigration if you
really think a dollar is a serious
argument and proposal is serious we're
in a serious negotiation the president
said the experts have told me it's gonna
take five point six billion dollars to
secure the American border what's your
alternative and she says a dollar Kamala
Harris from tonight we have a sound byte
for her this is how the left is
demagoguing this issue then start
talking about well african-americans and
Latinos don't want this this stuff
happening
I what was that supposed to be about
tell me that if not about about
inserting race in a way that was
intended to create fear and division I
thought sir well the fear and division
is coming from people who are tired of
seeing the drugs pour across our border
you know officer Singh's family there
are so many people like that and I've
seen story after story colleagues of
mine who shared stories with me about
deaths that have happened in their
districts from people who crossed here
illegally look every year we bring in
over a million people into our country
legally to seek the American Dream it's
the people that are coming across the
border illegally that are here to do bad
things drug dealers terrorists human
last year ice agents saved over 900
children from human trafficking what are
they going to say to those 900 kids or
they signed legislation today anti-human
trafficking legislation
I don't know forgot any any publicly I
do it was covered at all on the networks
if it was I missed it but it was
probably like a reader this president's
done more to try to stem some of the
tide of the bad things that are coming
across our border from drugs to human
trafficking to sexual assaults look at
the numbers over 30 percent of all the
women in the caravan have been sexually
assaulted because it's always it's not
real right hand on there oh by the way
Chuck Schumer voted for a similar wall
in 2006 Wow where was their indignation
on all of this was the president
petulant today the president never
banged is he he was very calm he was
trying to get her solution Nancy Pelosi
never once put an alternative on the
table not once and he looked at her and
said okay you keep saying you want to
open the government up again what if I
open it up for the next 30 days at the
end of 30 days we support the wall
without even blinking she said no and he
said okay well we're not getting
anywhere yeah the president tweeted
negotiations 101 the best deals you can
make are the ones you walk away from and
then get them with better terms a tweet
today congressman thank you so much
great to see you as always